cette décision de la france était
attendue même espérer au mali la junte
au pouvoir ne cachait pas son hostilité
vis-à-vis des français d'ailleurs paris
non plus bonjour anne fleur l'espion
vous retrouvez en direct de bamako se
retraite il vécu comme une libération
sur place
absolument il est vécu comme une
libération par une partie de la
population malienne et puis il y a peu
de temps l'armée malienne vient de
donner une conférence de presse en
réponse aux annonces des manuels macron
alors d'après le colonel dembélé ici à
bamako les armées étrangères ne pourront
pas mieux faire que les femmes allaient
forces armées maliennes lors de son
allocution le militaire a déclaré je
cite c'est notre pays est ce qu il donc
par cannes et les autres partenaires
militaires vont se battre comme nous la
réponse est non une réponse qui
s'inscrit dans la stratégie
souverainiste défendue par les autorités
de transition depuis maintenant des mois
une période également marquée par des
manifestations anti françaises un peu
partout au mali avec une population qui
dénonce la politique étrangère de la
france en afrique de l'ouest une pop il
une population qui s'est beaucoup
interrogé sur le bien fondé de
l'opération barkan qui après neuf ans
d'intervention au mali n'a pas réussi à
apporter une réponse à la crise
sécuritaire un majorité des maliens se
félicite donc je de retrait de la france
au profit de nouveaux partenaires comme
la russie et d'autres mais le départ de
barkan inquiète tout de même une frange
de la population dont certains cadres de
la classe politique pour le mali a
besoin aujourd'hui de tous ses fils de
tous ses amis et de tous ses partenaires
pour répondre aux défis sécuritaires
le mali n'a surtout pas besoin de
s'isoler il rappelle qu'en termes de
lutte contre le terrorisme
le mali est un pays un pays pivot au
coeur du sahel
l'agente ann fleurs a clairement poussé
barkan vers la sortie mais notons que le
mali n'a pas demandé formellement le
départ de la france
oui tout à fait et aujourd'hui on rentre
dans une période d'incertitude où bon
nombre de questions restent pour le
moment sans réponse concernant l'après
barkan pour rappel 7 millions de
personnes sur une population totale de
20 millions au mali sont dans l'attenté
d'une assistance humanitaire faute de
sécurité ces dernières semaines les
autorités de transition ont porté leur
attention sur la sécurité du pays en
annonçant la montée en puissance des
femmes à les forces armées maliennes qui
aurait permis d'affirmer tel retour de
la sécurité dans certaines localités du
centre du pays épicentre du conflit au
mali mais nous avons pu l'observer avec
la présence de barkan et autres
partenaires européens ou du g5 snel la
réponse militaire ne sera pas suffisante
pour répondre aux défis sécuritaires au
mali et plus largement sahel quel sera
l'impact sur les partenaires militaires
et humanitaires qui continue d'oeuvrer
sur le terrain c'est le cas de la
mission de maintien de la paix de l'onu
par exemple dont les positions sont
régulièrement ciblés par des attaques et
puis enfin quelle sera la réponse de
l'état pour répondre aux défis
sécuritaires les autorités de transition
entameront elle officiellement des
négociations avec les groupes
djihadistes qui contrôle aujourd'hui les
deux tiers du territoire malien merci
anne fleur l'espion